Okay, before things get too complicated, it's time we clear
up something that could cause use trouble later, and may
be causing some of you some stress, if you have
any experience with chromosomes before. This picture that you saw
earlier is, in fact, a real picture of human chromosomes
from a cell. Let's focus in on this pair of
chromosomes here. They sort of look like big Xs don't
they. I were to draw them in cartoon form, this is
how I would probably try to represent them. And although this is an accurate
representation of what you see here, in reality this type of chromosome is
called a duplicated chromosome. It's called a duplicated chromosome, because
each side of the X is actually identical to the other side.
And we refer to each of these sides as chromatids. In fact,
because they're so identical, we refer to them
as sister chromatids. This chromosome over here also
has sister chromatids. So we have one pair
of chromosomes, one pair of Xs, and they
each are composed of sister chromatids, which are
duplicated strands of each other. However, most of
the time, chromosomes look like this instead. They
don't look like an X. They're just one,
linear molecule. We call this a non-duplicated chromosome. This is what the pair
typically looks like in a cell.
Remember, linear chromosomes are just double-stranded DNA
in one really long molecule, wrapped up in histones proteins, into a higher
order structure that looks like the chromosome
we're used to seeing. But after duplication,
the double-stranded DNA is now copied and
now there are two copies, two double-stranded molecules
of DNA. And they're joined together in the middle here. And this is what makes
them look like these big Xs over
here. And because they're genetically identical We call
these sister chromatids here, within this X.
That's what the sister chromatids are. But we
still call the linear non-duplicated chromosome a chromosome,
and we call the duplicated version with sister
chromatids a chromosome. It's still a chromosome structure.
The reason most pictures you've seen of chromosomes
look like this is because this is when
they're most condensed and easy to see. As
you can imagine, DNA is like a big
loose string that's really long inside a cell, and
it's normally sort of loosey-goosey hanging out, but when a
cell divides, it has to organize and get everything together
and choreograph to separate And so it condenses into these
beautiful organized structures that make it easy for us to
see. So a scientist will wait until a cell gets
to this point, and then it opens the cell up
to see the chromosome. And because we're at this stage,
after the DNA's been duplicated, they look Like this x structure.
But they can also look like this non x or just linear structure. Now, I want
you to tell me. Of the following 4
groupings of chromosomes. Which of the following represents 4
chromosomes? Either duplicated or non duplicated. Pick which
ones represent 4 chromosomes. There can be multiple answers,
or there may not, so I want you to check all the boxes that you think apply.